welcome to level 4 multiplication let's
do some problems
say we had
times i'm going to use two different
colors here so bear with me a second
let's say times
7.
so you start a level 4 problem just like
you would normally do a level 3 problem
so we'll take that 7 and we'll multiply
it by 235
so 7 times 5 is 35
7 times 3
is 21 plus the 3 we just carried is 24
seven times two is fourteen
plus the two we just carried this is
sixteen so we're done with the seven now
we have to deal with this four well
since that four is in the tenths place
we add a zero here you could almost view
it as we're multiplying 235 not by four
but we're multiplying it by 40 and
that's why we put that zero there
so but once you put the zero there you
can treat it just like a four so you say
four times five well that's 20
20. let's ignore what we had from before
4 times 3 is 12 plus the 2 we just
carried which is 14.
4 times 2 is eight plus the one we just
carried so that's nine
and now we just add up everything
five plus zero is five four plus zero is
four
six plus four is ten
carry the 1
and 1 plus 1 plus 9 well that's 11. so
the answer is 11 045.
let's do another problem
let's say
i had
times and i'm making these numbers up on
the fly so so bear with me
873 times
some high numbers
90 and i'm doing them in different
colors just so you you hopefully you get
a better understanding of what i'm what
i'm trying to explain
let's say 97 now i just use a seven
let's make it 98.
so just like we did before we go to the
ones place first we're and that's where
that eight is and we multiply that eight
times eight hundred and seventy three
so eight times three
is twenty four
carry the two
eight times seven is fifty six
plus 2 is 58
carry the 5.
8 times 8 is 64
plus the 5 we just carried that's 69
we're done with the 8. and now we have
to multiply the 9 and or we could just
do it as we're multiplying the 873 by
90.
but multiplying something by 90 is just
the same thing as multiplying something
by nine and then adding a zero at the
end so that's why you put a zero right
here you say nine times three well let's
first just to clean up things let's get
rid of what we had from before we say 9
times 3 is 27
carry the 2
9 times 7 is 63 plus the 2 that we just
carried to 65
carry the six
nine times eight is 72 plus the six we
just carried that's 78
and now we just add again
8 plus seven is fifteen
one plus nine plus five is fifteen
one plus sev six plus eight is also
fifteen
and one plus seven that's eight so the
answer hopefully i don't have a
calculator in front of me is eighty five
thousand five hundred fifty four
assuming i didn't make any careless
mistakes
let's do one more problem i think it'll
it'll hit the point home
the next problem i'm gonna do you could
almost do it as a level five problem
because i'm actually gonna multiply two
three digit numbers but it's really the
same thing and hopefully you'll see the
pattern so let's say i had
times and i'm going to use three colors
now
let's say six hundred
and
forty
three
so first we do the three which is in the
ones place that we say and we multiply
that times 234
well three times four is twelve carry
the one
three times three is nine
add the one that's ten carry the one
three times two is six plus one well
that's seven
and then we've done the
i think i've made a mistake someplace
let me see
3 times 4 is 12.
i know i think that's that's that's
correct oh good good okay i was
confusing myself
okay now we're ready to do the 4 or the
40 and since it's a 40 because it's in
the tens place we put a 0 right here
we say 4 times 4 well let's let's clean
up this stuff at the top i always forget
to do that
4 times 4 well that's 16.
carry the 1. 4 times 3 well that's 12
plus 1.
well that's 13.
4 times 2 is 8 plus the 1. well that's
9.
and now we're done with the 4 or the 40
depending how you want to view it now
we're ready for the 6 or the 600 since
it's a 600 we put two zeros here
and we just treat it like a six and
let's clean up what we did before
so 6 times 4 is 24
carry the 2. 6 times 3 is 18 plus 2
is 20.
carry a 2. 6 times 2 is 12
plus 2 is 14.
and now we add it all up
two
six
seven plus three is ten fourteen carry
the one
one plus nine is ten
carry the one it's five
that's one i hope you can see it i hope
it's not falling off the screen but the
answer i get is 150
462.
i think you're ready now to try level
four multiplication problems